he's no no look at that he's seen it
now yes yes but he knows this might be
the last few moves of his world
championship oh my
[Music]
God move your king can you hear me no
definitely not move your king Frank I'm
biased I don't care do not take the Rook
oh my goodness he's doing it I think CR
of elimination he has to he has to or he
just he was ready to lose God damn oh my
God he's got a minute I'm going to lose
my mind that's damn good less than a
minute on the clock 58 seconds on the
clock he's no
no wow and he makes the t wait
wait
what Conor just leaves mate in one on
the board oh my goodness back it up back
it up a step replay Queen takes E8 is
check and mate the King has no Escape
here that's Checkmate oh my God instead
he autopilots Queen takes Queen which
seemed like a free but look two Rooks
and a bishop against Pawn black is still
winning this game this is just the
beginning for prananda and this is
finally the coveted World Cup title for
Carlson it's taken him a long time but
it seems like he is only moments away
from claiming the final feather in his
cap yeah I think we have to mention for
the the viewers who are not that
familiar with uh possessions that we
would never dare to speculate about this
kind of things if there would be real
tension in the position Black's problem
is however that he is forced with the
the decision that he has to depart from
his Rook on E3 he can't play the move
Rook A8 yes and there is a handshake
Rook takes E1 followed by a draw for
nothing nothing left to do 3 seconds
added every single move you make so a
quick check go block that pawn and then
push your own pawns Fabby can win this
game even if he loses Queen for those
two pawns then he can push the Pawns of
his own a rook can't stop but he give it
away with check wow he just blundered
the pawn with check he should have
pushed the other one the G Pawn wrong
choice there and Magnus is alive look at
those white pawns paralyzing the black
queen and this can be scary for black
because now the queen can't move
anywhere with the check without allowing
the D Pawn to promote and Magnus is does
he have enough to hold this well the
problem for Magnus is that g Pawn will
be a decoy it's about to sacrifice
itself The Rook on D3 can't move because
in the D7 Pawn in front of the queen
will be captured both sides they're
struggling a bit here five doesn't know
where to go but now it's winning for
Magnus he brings his Rook all the way
down Rook it he chooses the wrong Square
he trapped his own Queen and it's
handshakes Magnus Carson does the
unbelievable he wins down a Queen Bishop
a skewed any moment now we need to see
both players we might see a handshake
and we see Magnus he continues the
knight in The Rook our lined up Magnus
under 20 seconds but it's going to be
enough Wesley is he about to give up
it's hopeless nothing to do look at the
black pieces one of them will drop off
and he's trying one or two final tricks
here Wesley so but look at this both
pieces forked that's it and that's it
Magnus Carlton does it we have a winner
it is him it was always going to be him
Magnus Carlson the Undisputed king of
speed chess wins the Champions chest to
finals and you hear Wesley say something
towards
Magnus oh yeah
he's asking him about the
theory
uhuh yeah they were discussing their
opening it's all about the chest for
these guys but relief on Magnus Carson's
face we saw it suddenly a smile and he
deserves every moment he's got 15
seconds to find a move and Magnus closes
his eyes and goes all in and Rook Rook
A2 he missed it oh my goodness Rook
takes B6 again Rook takes P6 and it's
over Rook takes P6 over and he miss oh
my goodness he still has something maybe
for draw both Rooks are
sacrificed oh my this might be winning
by the way but he only needs a draw as
the match clock expires and Hikaru is
exasperated oh my gosh am on hikaro had
forced mate and it's a draw by agreement
and it's the match he offers a draw a
gentleman's draw and I mean what a
finish it literally comes down to the
last game and look at the smile on even
hikaru's face these guys are just two
Titans two Champions going at one
another da going for a little
cheeky
[Music]
SM please take that was so funny that
was so funny oh you can't the look at
that look at
the and joh
laughs Magnus like to a knight does does
Magnus have Auto Queen on take it and
get a knight take it yeah hold alt and
promote to a knight we're going to
definitely make sure Magnus knows
that that was that was good by the way
fans for the side joke in case you're
not realizing it's stalemate if you take
the Rook that's what's going on here and
Magus Magnus plays along oh that was so
good so good I don't think Magnus knows
how to that he is doesn't have to Auto
Queen if he holds down alt and Hammer
has experienced that his compatriot and
so his friend so da he gets a draw that
was hilarious a great way to end that
match rookie Queen f8 Rook E6 Queen f8
is even more beautiful now it's a threat
and he can do it queen f8 queen f8 queen
f8 queen f8 he sees
it and MBL applauding he applauds and
what else can you do Kasa but applaud
yeah that that golf clap was merited you
know we we all could applaud at home as
well that was that was nice can I tell
you my vision can I tell you my vision
right now uhhuh it is Bishop H6 for
white yeah if captures yep yep yep Fork
the fact that's a nice try yeah the fact
that you even see that is
impressive sees the cheeses yeah no I
mean that's now make no mistake this
move does nothing all no no it also
allows you to recapture the
night yes
yes oh my God that's why I'm the best
baby to discredit my vision is insane no
again it's minus 7 okay
he just needs to feel something Levy it
is literally only a good move if he
takes and I think he's going to take it
oh my
God oh my God wait
he's look at me witness me ly let's go
carter one D4 to which Jan responds by
developing his Knight all right next
question what is Yan going to play on
move
two must be
E6 must be E6
he play in the past in the past exactly
but in the world championship match and
in the candidates he he stuck to E6
great call and ding no nimzo for us
today he develops the Knight to F3 it's
got to be the C
yeah and indeed whoa what he Mouse no he
Mouse SLI the Jeep one is the one it's
the other one it's not that
one it happens you know H3 the board is
long he's play H3 it happens I mean he
tried to play G3 the the hand SLI to the
right and this is crazy this is crazy
wow credit because he kept his very
competitive in the Blitz and then Magnus
is able to run away with it down the
stretch here and
bullet exactly yeah Magnus playing I
would say Magnus is playing at his level
or maybe even a little bit beyond it Yan
however we talked about this before the
match if he wants to give himself a
chance he cannot lose games
unnecessarily but he did have a few
blonders here and there and yeah as we
see then you're just going to have a
tough day at the office against
Magnus every day is probably a tough day
against Magnus Carlson and in this
position magnet is stealing the queen
side he took B7 A6 is going to be loose
with that Knight on C7 oh his
Queen oh my goodness Magnus just forgot
a knight could capture his
queen and a B has gamut in the speed
chest Championship who would have fought
Robert what a what a spot and you know I
think Yan is still the only one who's
who spotted it and now look at them he's
seen it now oh wow look at his reaction
there that is a he's gone to have a
little lay down after that so uh a dear
look at that he's sitting in the corner
like a naughty child yeah so he now
realizes what he missed Queen takes G5 a
check made inent three and Magnus
Carlson can't believe it I don't think
we've ever seen a reaction like that
we've nearly never seen a missed
opportunity like that from the world's
best player and who's going to recover
Magnus looks to draw he's had enough
now and then hikaro Nakamura it's a big
day for you hikaro Nakamura is coming up
in the next match what can we expect
from that one um I don't know I haven't
thought too much about it yet but um I I
mean I guess he won a fairly convincing
match now so at least he's showing um
showing some signs of improvement
thank you for joining us minus good luck
in the next match thank you it looks
like an easy draw three on two on one
side a pass Pawn on the other but the
Rook stands behind the pass Pawn
Benjamin that was weird we're not used
to seeing Magnus spend so much time like
that in positions with great winning
chances exactly yeah now I guess he's
just going to wait he lost he lost on
time he lost on time and look at Yan's
face he's a disbelief and Magnus is
furious what was he thinking
about I don't know what happened I don't
here's the thing Robert maybe he wanted
to play Rook A1 to H1 but the move is so
far across the board that it took him
too long to make a move players The Rook
slides back to A1 if Pawn F2 King can
slide to G2 just in time just push the H
Pawn H5 H6 KN G4 the pawn again Knight
takes F2 oh and that's a great move to
throw because now the knights are stuck
with each other and now trades are
happening and the H Pawn will win the
and then Rook A3 you pin and you sack
and then you push the H Pawn you're in
time this Pawn is too slow
white wins the game and it's the last
game of the match it's the last game of
the match time is
up oh my goodness so Paulina is going to
win don't pre-move don't need to
pre-move here oh my
goodness and Levy just notices and
Paulina sha leans back she puts her
hands in the air like she just don't
care she has won the
IMC ter okay but when your opponent is
way way way way down it's more than
enough it's your vs bro you strugg to
get squeaks and that dude
sucks well I mean 15 minutes against him
well okay well squeaks is really really
really really bad you're not wrong um I
mean the guy was he was he was wearing a
wig that's is enough about him he was
wearing a wig during a tournament think
that's true that is insane I not iure
from the start that's true that's
true
is he playing for a win is dingly Ren
trying to win this game on he goes Queen
C7 which is a mistake a huge mistake in
time trouble from y pomp the queen has
to go back to G6 that's the good news
for dingly
Ren yeah I think this is over oh my gosh
so close to
disaster
[Music]
it's over dingler is the world CH
Champion I cannot believe it but dingly
Ren a deserving world
[Music]
champion
the moment I yeah resigned the game it
was a very emotional moment I cannot uh
control my my feelings and yes and I
know myself I will cry I will burst into
tears
[Music]
you